it's time for a little Jedi training
cultivate the force let's talk about
meditation
I absolutely sock it meditation I'm also
really great at meditation meditation is
the hardest thing in the world to do
it's also the easiest thing in the world
to do sometimes I cannot stop the
chatter in my mind bla bla bla like a
swarm of bees in my head and other times
it's like complete peace no mind and
that is the beautiful and also the
infuriating thing about meditation let
me back up I was first introduced to
meditation in of all places rehab in
1998 where I live for a hundred days to
finally confront my alcoholism my
Stanford education my Cornell Law degree
my best thinking landed me in what is
essentially without mincing words a
mental institution and at the time I've
been living my life based on self will
they call it self well run riot
meanwhile I'd become deeply profoundly
unhappy chasing this life this myth of
the American dream that I had never ever
for one moment stopped to consider or
think or ponder whether it was actually
the right life for me and it wasn't
until I was in that rehab 17 18 years
ago that I actually hit pause on my life
for the very first time and started to
put some thought and some intention
behind the kind of life that I wanted to
lead the kind of life that I wanted to
live and I very vividly remember
during the early days of that rehab stay
a counselor came up to me and he said
rich are you a human being having a
spiritual experience or are you a
spiritual being having a human
experience and I was like what I don't
understand the question I had no idea
what he was talking about but now I do
understand the question I understand it
deeply and completely and the answer is
that we are all spiritual beings having
a human experience and the way that I
arrived at this conclusion is through
one singular practice meditation I can
tell you from experience that when I
meditate and do it consistently
everything in my life is better now look
I am no expert in meditation but I have
learned a couple of things I'm going to
tell you about those things but first
check out this sweet view
there is no wrong way to meditate it's
so easy to get caught up in all the
details and the minutiae of all these
various practices and there's so many
practices practices based on mantra
practices based on the breath or
visualization and the truth is they're
all great but it's a mistake to get
caught up in these details and use them
as an excuse to prevent yourself from
just beginning the truth is the best
method is the one that you will actually
do the idea of course with meditation is
you want to achieve this state of
no-mind where thoughts are not invading
your consciousness where you are truly
in the now but of course thoughts are
going to invade your efforts to be
present we're human beings it's natural
that's just what happens it's completely
okay the trick is when you notice these
thoughts invading your mind just move
forward dismiss them and don't judge
yourself my friend Charlie Knowles
teaches Vedic meditation he has a great
saying he said it on my podcast and that
saying goes like this
there is no failure in meditation there
is just do or do not and I love that
just begin
consistency is king if you're anything
like me your good intentions your good
habits they go in waves you have 30 days
of total awesomeness and then you fall
off a cliff and then you repeat the
cycle over and over and over again I
know what that's like I've done that a
million times and that's okay but if you
can find the resolve to prioritize
meditation by setting aside even just
five minutes every morning I think
that's a huge win don't set yourself up
for failure or burnout by committing to
like an hour every morning or meditating
twice a day if you know in your heart of
hearts that you're not going to be able
to live up to it that it's just not
going to fit into your current lifestyle
I think instead it's much better to
commit to something totally doable and
that way you can create positive
momentum by consistently meeting that
achievable goal and then over time as
you start to see and experience the
positive results you can up the ante how
awesome is this tree incredible
let go of your story it's not helping
you this whole idea that I can't sit
still my mind is just spinning too fast
I'm too busy I'm just not the meditation
type all of that is absolute bunk you
have time just make it a priority
get off Facebook get off Twitter
Instagram snapchat Netflix whatever go
to bed earlier wake up earlier shift
your perspective and change the story
you tell yourself about yourself and
your relationship to meditation and I
think what you'll find over time with
consistent practice is that it really
isn't that hard it can be easy because
the mind is very plastic like that also
I think it's really important to not
over intellectualize it you don't have
to understand every aspect or facet of
meditation to just begin because all of
that is like mental masturbation it's
like this barrier that prevents you from
actually just starting and finally don't
judge yourself against some ideal you
have in your mind about how it's
supposed to go in fact don't judge
yourself at all just let all of that go
if you're brand new to meditation I
strongly suggest checking out Julie
that's my wife her guided humming
meditation program it's this really
great guided technique that removes all
the thinking out of the practice you
actually don't have to really do
anything except follow along you can
find that on my website ritual calm and
I'll put a link to it below
alternatively I would suggest checking
out the headspace app it's a free app
for your phone I keep it on my dock
right there at the bottom comes
pre-loaded with 10 10 minute guided
meditation sessions I use it all the
time and it's been very helpful with
keeping me on track if you want to learn
more about meditation in my perspective
on meditation I've done a number of
podcasts on the subject matter many
conversations with a whole litany of
incredible people everybody from my
friends Charlie Knowles and light
walkins who are both Vedic meditation
teachers I've done two episodes with a
Buddhist monk named Wu de Jason garner
who's a former music executive turned
meditation expert
and also I've even had the co-founder of
headspace Andy put a column on the show
all of them are amazing you can find the
podcast on iTunes I'll put links to
those specific episodes below 2016 is a
year that I prioritize meditation in a
new and very uncompromising way and I
can tell you that it's already paying
gigantic dividends in my life everything
from reduce stress and anxiety reduction
in irritability because my natural state
is to be very irritable so that's very
helpful
far less reactivity increased mental
acuity a sense of feeling calm and being
much more anchored in the present moment
it's helping me sleep better and perhaps
most profoundly it's helping me work
more efficiently and productively I let
go of running my life based on self well
back in 1998 when I was in that rehab
and when I'm devoted to a very
consistent meditation practice I find
that working towards my goals and
achieving my goals tends to come with
this enhanced sense of ease as opposed
to strain and struggle and stress and
strife and conflict and that alone is a
really gigantic gift so this is my
invitation to you to commit to 30 days
of consistent meditation practice and if
after that period you feel like it's not
working meditation is not for me
well I will gladly reimburse you your
irritability your stress your anxiety
and your general frustration with your
life
there is do and there is do not I choose
do and so should you
no-mind